This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. If you live in an American city and you walk outside to a major intersection and look into the streets, you know what you'll see. You'll see cars and trucks and buses. You might see a few bicycles trying to sneak their way through the traffic. What you won't see are people, not in the street anyway. Maybe on the sidewalk waiting for their turn to cross and then crossing quickly, hurrying to get out of the way so that the cars can get going again.
这里是《99% Invisible》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。如果你住在美国的城市里，走到一个主要路口，看向街道，你肯定知道你会看到什么。你会看到汽车、卡车和公共汽车。你可能还会看到几辆自行车试图在车流中穿行。但你不会看到人，至少在街道上看不到。也许他们会在人行道上等着过马路，然后匆匆穿过，赶紧避开，好让汽车继续行驶。
In recent times, some of us have come to think the city streets shouldn't just be for cars and trucks. That cars take up too much space and release too much carbon. Just to move a couple of people a short distance. But even those anti-car haters, and I am one, we know the streets belong to our enemy. We look both ways before crossing. We don't let our children play in the streets. We might sometimes jaywalk across the street at the wrong place her time, but we know in our heart of hearts we're in the wrong.
近来，我们中的一些人开始认为城市街道不应该只属于汽车和卡车。汽车占用了太多空间，排放了太多碳，而仅仅是为了把几个人送往短距离的地方。但即使是那些反车人士——我也是其中之一——我们也知道街道属于我们的敌人。我们在过马路前会左右看。我们不让孩子在街上玩耍。我们有时可能会在错误的时间或地点乱穿马路，但我们内心深处知道我们这样做是不对的。
Scott Flos. That's our reporter, Jesse Duges. Because I actually love cars, but just I just don't think they make sense in the city. And this is a story about J-walking. Where that word J-walking came from, and how it was a weapon and a turf war between the people who wanted cars in the streets, and everybody else, you can probably guess who won. Alright, there's a wonderful cartoon in the St. Louis Post dispatch from 1923. It's called the Modern Malok, and Malok was a deity of the Ammonites. And this is Peter Norton, a historian at the University of Virginia who studies city
斯科特·弗洛斯。那是我们的记者杰西·杜克斯。因为我其实很喜欢汽车，只是我觉得它们在城市里并不合理。这是一个关于“乱穿马路”（Jaywalking）的故事。这个词是怎么来的，它如何成为一场武器和地盘争夺战，发生在那些想要汽车在街上行驶的人和其他所有人之间，你大概能猜到谁赢了。好吧，1923年的《圣路易斯邮报》上有一幅精彩的漫画。它叫《现代摩洛克》，摩洛克是亚扪人崇拜的神。这位是弗吉尼亚大学研究城市街道的历史学家彼得·诺顿。
streets. Malok was a deity to whom the Ammonite sacrificed their own children in return for prosperity. What an image for what the car was because the idea is that you were sacrificing our children in the name of modern technology. According to Peter Norton, there was a time in the 1920s when it looked like public opinion was against having cars in the streets. In this particular cartoon, you see a driver kneeling at an altar, which is the front grill of a car, with a huge bowl full of the corpses of children, offering it up to the
摩洛克是一位神，亚扪人为了换取繁荣，会向他献祭自己的孩子。这对于汽车的形象来说是一个多么贴切的比喻，因为其理念是，你正在以现代技术的名义牺牲我们的孩子。据彼得·诺顿说，在20世纪20年代，曾有一段时间，公众舆论似乎反对让汽车在街上行驶。在这幅特定的漫画中，你看到一个司机跪在祭坛前，祭坛就是汽车的前格栅，上面放着一个装满儿童尸体的大碗，作为祭品献给
mouth of this machine beast as a sacrifice. It's a very striking cartoon. And it may seem a little bizarre to us today until you recognize that this thing was killing thousands of children every year. Ah! So that was 1923, 90 years ago. But to understand why cars were being compared
这个机器野兽的嘴。这是一幅非常震撼的漫画。在今天看来，这可能显得有点离奇，直到你意识到这东西每年都在杀死成千上万的孩子。啊！所以那是1923年，90年前的事了。但要理解为什么汽车会被比作
to a child eating God, we've gotta go back a few more years. And so if you went back 110 years, I think you'd be amazed to see people just strolling right into the street, any place, any time, sure they'll look, but not very carefully. At the turn of the century, there was nothing moving faster than about 5 or 10 miles an hour in the street. Responsible parents would say to their children, go outside and play in the streets all day. Even after the first cars appeared in the cities, right around 1900, they had to conform to the customs of the day, which meant that traffic moved slowly.
吃孩子的神，我们得再往回追溯几年。如果你回到110年前，我想你会惊讶地看到人们随意地走进街道，任何地方，任何时间，当然他们会看一眼，但不会非常小心。在世纪之交，街上没有任何东西的速度超过每小时5到10英里。负责任的父母会告诉他们的孩子，去外面在街上玩一整天。即使在第一批汽车出现在城市之后，大约在1900年左右，它们也必须遵守当时的习俗，这意味着交通移动得很慢。
There's wonderful video, like 1905 people walking down Market Street in San Francisco before the earthquake and people are just striding right in wherever they want to go. Children, people carrying you know boards of wood, people going about their business. It's not to say that the street off of the sidewalks for everybody because people prefer the sidewalk. It's not to say that the street off of the sidewalks for everybody because people prefer the sidewalk, it's drier, it's cleaner, it's got less horse manure. And there weren't even really many rules about what you could do or not do. People are solving problems the way they solve problems when you're walking in a crowded hallway, like, you know, in a school building between classes and you have huge crowd of
有一段精彩的视频，比如1905年地震前人们走在旧金山的市场街上，人们只是大步流星地走在他们想去的任何地方。孩子们，搬着木板的人，忙着自己事情的人。这并不是说街道对所有人来说都比人行道好，因为人们更喜欢人行道。这并不是说街道对所有人来说都比人行道好，因为人们更喜欢人行道，它更干燥，更干净，马粪更少。而且对于你能做什么或不能做什么，甚至没有什么真正的规则。人们解决问题的方式就像你在拥挤的走廊里行走时解决问题的方式一样，比如，你知道，在课间休息时的教学楼里，你有一大群
kids or something trying to find their way. And they start to figure stuff out like, you know, usually keep right while you're walking. There's not like a law, you know, but there's an understanding. You go that way, I'll go this way, I'll keep it right. I'll get that guys. I'm going to go to the right. I'll go to the left.
孩子或其他什么人试图找到他们的路。他们开始弄清楚一些事情，比如，你知道，走路时通常靠右。这不像是一条法律，你知道，但有一种默契。你走那边，我走这边，我会靠右。我会避开那个人。我要往右走。我会往左走。
What are you from England? And I think the closest thing we have to that now is a city park, or maybe a pedestrian mall. You go to a city park and you're mostly guided by understandings, understandings like you can use the park for whatever you want provided. You don't endanger other people. You don't break the law and you don't make a nuisance out
你是英国人吗？我想我们现在拥有的最接近那种感觉的地方是城市公园，或者可能是步行街。你去城市公园，你主要受默契引导，比如只要你不危及他人，不触犯法律，不造成滋扰，你就可以随意使用公园。
of yourself. And then you're pretty much okay. And it's a lot like that in streets. But by 1922 things changed. For one, cities in America were filling up with people. This was right in the midst of the industrial revolution when Americans were leaving farms to move to cities to work in factories
然后你基本上就没事了。街道上也是如此。但到了1922年，情况发生了变化。首先，美国的城市里挤满了人。这正处于工业革命中期，当时美国人正离开农场搬到城市去工厂工作，
or maybe in the middle class of their lucky. So the streets were starting to get more crowded. You've probably heard of the other big change, the Model T Ford, the first affordable automobile, introduced in 1908, mass produced in 1913. Price is just falling every year by 1920, a new Model T without any extras, you could get for $300.
或者如果他们幸运的话，进入中产阶级。所以街道开始变得更加拥挤。你可能听说过另一个重大变化，福特T型车，第一款负担得起的汽车，1908年推出，1913年大规模生产。价格每年都在下降，到1920年，一辆没有任何额外配置的新T型车，你只需300美元就能买到。
And this is really now in the reach of the working class, the people who make the Ford Model T can afford to buy it. That was a principal dear to the heart of Henry Ford. So by the 1920s, cities are crowding with people. And these people are buying cars and driving cars in the streets. Drivers don't want to drive five or 10 or 15 miles an hour. The speed at which street traffic is moved for decades,
这现在真的在工薪阶层的承受范围内了，制造福特T型车的人买得起它。这是亨利·福特心中坚持的原则。所以到了20世纪20年代，城市里挤满了人。这些人正在买车并在街上开车。司机们不想以每小时5、10或15英里的速度行驶，这是几十年来街道交通的速度，
they want to drive faster. And the pedestrians and children still linger in the streets, walking casually like its 1906 and every year more people are killed in automobile accidents. The fatalities are rising and you can watch the curve, you know, it's like climbing a mountain. You're just going uphill the whole way. By 1923, you've got about 17, 18,000 people a year being killed by motor vehicles. Three-quarters of those people are pedestrians. And half of the pedestrians killed in the cities are children, under the age of 16. And as far as the public is concerned, it's almost like they died in a war.
他们想开得更快。而行人和孩子们仍然在街上徘徊，像1906年那样随意行走，每年都有更多的人死于交通事故。死亡人数在上升，你可以观察这条曲线，你知道，就像爬山一样。你一直在上坡。到1923年，每年约有17,000到18,000人死于机动车事故。其中四分之三是行人。而在城市中死亡的行人中，有一半是16岁以下的儿童。就公众而言，这几乎就像他们死于战争一样。
Parades are held in dozens of cities to commemorate the dead children. Monuments are built. Mothers of children killed in the streets are given a special white star to honor their laws. And that's why in 1923, we see a cartoon comparing the automobile to Malaq, a god who demands the sacrifice of children for prosperity.
几十个城市举行游行来纪念死去的孩子。纪念碑被建立起来。在街上丧生的孩子的母亲们被授予一枚特殊的白星以纪念她们的损失。这就是为什么在1923年，我们看到一幅漫画将汽车比作摩洛克，一个要求以牺牲儿童来换取繁荣的神。
And we get lots of newspaper articles and editorials saying this blood bath has to end, and almost all of them blame the deaths on the automobile, like this from the New York Times. The horrors of war appear to be less appalling than the horrors of peace. The automobile looms up as a far more destructive mechanism than the machine gun. The reckless motorist deals more death than the artilleryman. The man in the street seems less safe than the man in the trench. The greatest single lethal factor is the automobile. It left shambles in its wake as a course to through 1923.
我们看到许多报纸文章和社论说这场血腥屠杀必须结束，几乎所有文章都将死亡归咎于汽车，就像《纽约时报》的这篇报道一样。“战争的恐怖似乎不如和平的恐怖令人震惊。汽车作为一个破坏性机制，比机枪更可怕。鲁莽的驾驶者造成的死亡比炮兵更多。街上的人似乎比战壕里的人更不安全。最大的单一致命因素是汽车。”它在1923年一路走来留下了混乱。
The New York Times of 23rd, 1924. In cities begin to think seriously about restricting the use of cars in the cities. City managers look at outlawing curb parking or forcing cars to make right-angle turns around obstacles and intersections so they have to slow to a crawl. Now by 1923, a whole cottage industry has grown up around the automobile. There are the manufacturers, of course, but also the dealers who have been making a lot of money in the last few years. And there are motor clubs, which were precursors to AAA and make a lot of money selling
1924年的《纽约时报》。城市开始认真考虑限制城市中汽车的使用。城市管理者考虑取缔路边停车，或者强迫汽车在障碍物和路口处进行直角转弯，这样它们就不得不减速到爬行速度。现在到了1923年，围绕汽车已经形成了一个完整的配套产业。当然有制造商，还有过去几年赚了很多钱的经销商。还有汽车俱乐部，它们是AAA的前身，通过销售会员资格赚了很多钱。
memberships. So, according to Peter Norton, there's a moment when all of these interests start to worry the city laws are going to make it so nobody in the city would want to buy a car and have a collective, oh crap moment. Oh, that's really clear. It's really sharp. The oh crap moment is November 1923. I love that. So what happened then?
所以，据彼得·诺顿说，有一个时刻，所有这些利益相关者开始担心城市法律会使城市里没有人想买车，并产生了一种集体的“糟糕了”时刻。哦，这真的很清楚。这真的很敏锐。那个“糟糕了”时刻是1923年11月。我喜欢这个。那么后来发生了什么？
All right. So Cincinnati residents got a referendum on the ballot to be voted on in November for a speed governor a device built into the engine that would require cars to be equipped with one that would limit them to 25 miles an hour and once the speed governor was there it had a police seal on it if you tampered with it you were in violation of the law. This had lots of popular support. We know 40,000 signatures on petitions. You know, can't swear that they were all real people or so on, but they were 40,000 signatures on the petitions. They had newspaper advertisements saying, vote yes on this. This really woke up people who wanted a future for cars and cities. They were worried that if cities had laws that restricted the use of cars, the people would stop buying them, not for public transportation instead. Cars would be relegated to the countryside where fewer and fewer people lived every year.
好吧。辛辛那提的居民在11月的选票上获得了一项公投，投票决定是否安装限速器，这是一种内置在发动机中的装置，要求汽车必须配备，将其限制在每小时25英里，一旦安装了限速器，上面就有警察的封条，如果你篡改它，你就违反了法律。这得到了广泛的民众支持。我们知道请愿书上有40,000个签名。你知道，不能保证他们都是真实的人等等，但请愿书上确实有40,000个签名。他们有报纸广告说，投赞成票。这真的唤醒了那些想要汽车在城市中有未来的人。他们担心如果城市有限制汽车使用的法律，人们就会停止购买汽车，而不是改用公共交通。汽车将被降级到乡村，那里每年居住的人越来越少。
And this group of interests got organized, and even gave themselves a name. They call themselves Motordom. Motordom. Actually, that sounds pretty benign to my ears. Anyway. And they start to make distinctions between what they want and what the other safety advocates wanted. So, you start to see, like, in the Cincinnati inquireer, which was sort of a mouthpiece for the auto industry in Cincinnati, they ran a huge amount of their advertising was from auto dealers. The Cincinnati inquirer at one point says the cause of accidents is men not machines.
这群利益相关者组织了起来，甚至给自己起了一个名字。他们称自己为“汽车王国”（Motordom）。汽车王国。其实，在我听来这听起来相当温和。不管怎样。他们开始区分他们想要的和那些安全倡导者想要的。所以，你开始看到，比如在《辛辛那提问询报》上，它算是辛辛那提汽车行业的喉舌，他们刊登了大量的广告，都是来自汽车经销商的。《辛辛那提问询报》在某一点上说，事故的原因是人而不是机器。
In other words, cars don't kill people. People kill people, which is reminiscent of an NRA motto that's been around for quite some time. Guns don't kill people, people kill people. It's the same basic idea. You can exonerate the machine if you blame the driver. It wasn't so much about blaming the driver. It was about promoting a subtle but super important distinction. The cause of accidents and deaths and children dying wasn't cars or speed. It was recklessness. Cars could be perfectly safe in the streets. They belonged on the streets. And the beauty of recklessness. Cars could be perfectly safe in the streets. They belonged on the streets.
换句话说，汽车不会杀人。人杀人，这让人想起全国步枪协会（NRA）存在已久的一句座右铭。枪不会杀人，人杀人。这是同样的基本理念。如果你责怪司机，你就可以免除机器的责任。这与其说是责怪司机，不如说是为了推广一个微妙但极其重要的区别。事故、死亡和儿童死亡的原因不是汽车或速度。而是鲁莽。汽车在街上可以非常安全。它们属于街道。而鲁莽的美妙之处在于……汽车在街上可以非常安全。它们属于街道。
And the beauty of recklessness is that you could also be a reckless pedestrian. This is really important. What Moderna did by suggesting that pedestrians could be reckless could be the cause of accidents with start a turf war. A street fight. The Ocrap moment in 1923 creates a clear sense in
而鲁莽的美妙之处在于，你也可以是一个鲁莽的行人。这非常重要。汽车王国通过暗示行人可能是鲁莽的，可能是事故的原因，从而引发了一场地盘争夺战。一场街头斗争。1923年的“糟糕了”时刻在汽车王国中创造了一种清晰的感觉，
Moderna that they have to change the problem from how do we control cars and drivers into how do we make streets places where cars belong and where pedestrians don't belong. Moderna needed to market the idea that accidents could be the result of reckless pedestrians, and even that there was such a thing as reckless pedestrians, which people weren't ready to accept yet. One judge in particular angrily denounced the idea that you could ever have such a thing
他们必须把问题从“我们如何控制汽车和司机”转变为“我们如何使街道成为汽车所属的地方，而行人不属于那里”。汽车王国需要推销这样一种理念：事故可能是鲁莽行人的结果，甚至存在“鲁莽行人”这种东西，而人们还没准备好接受这一点。一位法官特别愤怒地谴责了“你可能会有鲁莽行人”这种想法。
as a reckless pedestrian. So to sell the idea of reckless pedestrians, Moderna invented a new word, J-Walking. Well, actually, they didn't invent it. Moderna repurposed a word that had been kicking around for a couple of decades. They transformed it from a slaying insult to a legal term. In the 1910s, J, J-A-Y, was a word for country bumpkin.
所以为了推销“鲁莽行人”的理念，汽车王国发明了一个新词：Jaywalking（乱穿马路）。嗯，其实他们并没有发明它。汽车王国重新利用了一个已经流传了几十年的词。他们把它从一个俚语侮辱变成了一个法律术语。在1910年代，“Jay”这个词是指乡巴佬。
Therefore, a J-Walker is somebody who walks around the city like a J from the sticks. Well, the first actually clear illustration of what the word means that I found is from Kansas City 1911 and there it's describing, and they actually have a cartoon that shows a J Walker. They're describing the J Walker there as exactly that, the person from the countryside who's in the big city and is so dazzled by the show windows, the lights, the tall buildings, the salesmen and so on, that as they're walking on the sidewalk they're constantly stopping to look and thereby obstructing other pedestrians. So their J. Walker is really a nuisance
因此，一个“Jaywalker”就是一个像乡巴佬一样在城市里乱走的人。好吧，我发现的第一个关于这个词含义的清晰例证来自1911年的堪萨斯城，那里有描述，他们甚至有一幅漫画展示了一个“Jaywalker”。他们把那里的“Jaywalker”描述为正是那样，一个来自乡村的人，在大城市里被橱窗、灯光、高楼、推销员等等弄得眼花缭乱，以至于当他们在人行道上走时，他们不断停下来看，从而阻碍了其他行人。所以他们的“Jaywalker”确实是对其他行人的滋扰。
to other pedestrians. So Moderna took this word that had meant a kind of annoying pedestrian and gave it a new meaning, a pedestrian who breaks the traffic rules, who enters the streets in the wrong place or at the wrong time. They did this by publishing editorials about J-Walking. Auto clubs and auto dealers got boy scouts in a number of cities to hand out little cards that would say something like, did you know you were J-walking? And we know that people don't know what the word meant because it was carefully explained on the card with diagrams and information. And at first the efforts to get people to stop doing
所以汽车王国采用了这个原本指代一种烦人行人的词，并赋予了它新的含义：一个违反交通规则，在错误地点或错误时间进入街道的行人。他们通过发表关于“乱穿马路”的社论来做到这一点。汽车俱乐部和汽车经销商让许多城市的童子军分发小卡片，上面写着类似“你知道你在乱穿马路吗？”的话。我们知道人们不知道这个词是什么意思，因为卡片上用图表和信息仔细解释了它。起初，让人们停止做他们几十年来一直做的事情的努力根本没有奏效。甚至发生过一起事件，据一家报纸报道，妇女们用遮阳伞击打警察，因为警察试图控制她们如何过马路。对汽车王国的教训是，你不能通过法律来做到这一点。但最终，汽车王国想出了一个制胜策略，由……E.B.莱珀茨（E.B. Leperts）设计。E.B.莱珀茨。到处都是乱穿马路者的敌人。
something they had done for decades just didn't work. There was even an incident where according to a newspaper, women struck police officers with their parasols for trying to control how they crossed the street. The lesson for Moderdum was, you can't do this by law. But finally, Moderdum hit upon a winning strategy, devised by... E.B. Leperts. E.B. Leperts. Enemy of J. Walker's everywhere.
他是南加州汽车俱乐部的负责人，我认为他超越了他的时代，是一个真正的公关天才，一个在大多数人之前就意识到你不能仅仅通过惩罚人们和制定法律来改变行为的人。你必须通过心理学来触及他们。莱珀茨在洛杉矶发起了一场公关运动，解释什么是“乱穿马路”，并帮助在1924年通过了一项反“乱穿马路”条例。但这里最聪明的部分是。他告诉警察不要逮捕乱穿马路的人。莱珀茨希望警察不要逮捕乱穿马路的人，那只会
He was the head of the automobile club of Southern California, and I think he was ahead of his time a real public relations genius, a guy who realized before most others did that you can't just change behavior by punishing people and putting laws up. You have to reach them through psychology. Leffert's created a PR campaign in Los Angeles explaining what J-walking was, and he helped get an anti-J-walking ordinance passed in 1924. But here's the really clever part. He told the police not to arrest J-walkers. Leffert's wanted the police officer not to arrest the J-Walker, which would only
让乱穿马路的人感到愤慨，而是要引起嘲笑。他用了“嘲笑”这个词。哦，这真是交通的阻碍。别只是跑去药店买大麻。我们到了。嘿，你，离开街道，你没意识到你在乱穿马路吗？嘿，乱穿马路的人！真是个笑话，我吗？
make the J-Walker indignant, but to attract ridicule. And he uses the word ridicule. Oh, it's a damp and a traffic. Not just pop over to the drugists for some cannabis. Here we are. Hey you, out of the street, don't you realize you're Jay Walker? Hey, Jay Walker! What a joke, what me?
乱穿马路的人？哦，我妈妈会怎么想！莱珀茨希望行人被嘲笑，作为一种心理控制形式。对莱珀茨来说，让旁观者看到这个人被嘲笑，比你真正把这个人转化为正确的过马路行为更重要。旁观者会目睹这种嘲笑，并想：“我不想受到那种嘲笑，所以我得小心过马路。”
Jay Walker? Oh, my mother think! Lefferts wanted the pedestrian ridiculed as a form of psychological control. And to Lefferts, it was more important that the onlookers see this person being ridiculed than that you actually convert this individual to correct crossing behavior. The onlookers are going to witness this ridicule and think, I don't want to get that ridicule so I'm going to cross carefully.
这真是极其聪明。是的。现在很难与之产生共鸣，因为“乱穿马路”现在是一个相当温和的词，就像“游荡”一样，但在1920年代的美国，它是一个真正的辱骂词，实际上几位法官和报纸编辑都反对对行人使用这种侮辱性词汇。
That's fiendishly clever. Yeah. It's a little hard to relate to now, because J. Walker is sort of a benign word, like loitering, but in 1920s America, it was a real term of abuse, and actually several judges and newspaper editors objected to the use of such an insulting term for pedestrians.
它带有“白痴”的含义。我想如果你试图进行一场涉及称呼人们为白痴的公共安全运动，你今天会发现类似的反应。你知道，人们真的会反对这一点。或者想象一些更现代的东西。哦，这真是交通的阻碍。别只是跑去药店买大麻。我们到了。嘿，你，离开街道，你没意识到你在乱穿马路吗？你刚才对我说了什么？我吗？一个混蛋？我妈妈会怎么想？问题是，嘲笑奏效了。报纸报道显示，仅仅几周后，洛杉矶的行人们就明白了信息，
It carried the connotation of idiot. I think if you were trying to sort of have a public safety campaign that involved calling people idiots, you would find a similar kind of reaction today. You know, people would really object to that. Or imagine something even more contemporary. Oh, it's a damp and a traffic. Not just pop over to the drugist for some cannabis. Here we are. Hey you, out of the street, don't you realize you douchebagging? What did you show me? What me? A douchebag? What would my mother think? The thing is, the ridicule worked. Newspaper reports show that just after a few weeks, pedestrians in LA got the message,
街道被清理出来留给汽车。彼得·诺顿说，汽车王国到1929年可以宣布胜利。巧合的是，或者也许并非那么巧合，这一年美国建造了第一个苜蓿叶形立交桥，巩固了国家与汽车的未来。顺便说一句，大约在那个时候，你发现人们停止反对“乱穿马路者”这个词，包括乱穿马路者自己，你知道，法官们也不再抵制了。新的城市街道在设计时考虑到了汽车。街道变得更宽以容纳更多的汽车。新的企业被要求提供停车场。人行横道成为强制性的，城市开始修建高速公路，使汽车进出城市变得更容易。
and the streets were cleared for cars. Peter Norton says, Moderna could declare victory by 1929. Coincidentally, or maybe not so coincidentally, this was the year the first clover leaf interchange was built in the United States, cementing the country's future with automobile. Incidentally, that's around the time that you find that people stop objecting to the term J-Walker, including J-Walkers themselves, and you know, judges are no longer resisting that. And new city streets are built with cars in mind. The streets get wider to accommodate more cars. New businesses are required to provide parking lots. Crosswalks become compulsory, and cities start building expressways to make it easier to get cars in and out of cities.
值得花点时间反思一下这个故事是如何被讲述的。乔治·奥威尔解释说，历史是由胜利者书写的，因为在书写历史时，你证明了你自己的合理性。因此，汽车的历史不是由任何个人书写的，而是随着时间的推移集体书写的，这主要是汽车的胜利者历史。这就是那种认为这是不可避免的历史，它与美国对汽车的迷恋有关。在那些早年，美国似乎并没有对汽车有强烈的热情。这肯定不是一见钟情。事实上，你知道吗，Facebook和让汽车流行起来？让一些女孩流行起来的同样的东西。
And it's worth thinking a moment to reflect on how this story has been told. Uh, George Orwell explained that, uh, history is written by the winners because in writing the history, you justify yourself. So a history of the automobile has been written not by any single individual, but collectively over time, that predominantly is a winner's history of the automobile. And that's the history that says this was inevitable, and it has to do with America's love affair with the automobile. And those early years it hardly seemed that America had a consuming passion for the automobile. It certainly wasn't love at first sight. In fact, you know what, Facebook and to make the car popular? The same thing that made some girls popular.
它们以速度快而闻名。1961年有一个电视节目叫《杜邦周刊》，它自称是一个纪录片电视节目。当时的杜邦公司在通用汽车拥有三分之一的股份，所以两家公司有很多共同点。于是他们写了一集叫《我们快乐地前行》，这是美国汽车的历史。他们请格劳乔·马克斯（Groucho Marx）来主持，在这个节目中，格劳乔·马克斯向美国人介绍了
They got a reputation for being fast. In 1961 there was a TV program called the DuPont Show of the Week, which represented itself as a documentary TV show. And DuPont at that time had a one-third interest in general motors, so the two companies had a lot in common. And so they wrote an episode called Marily We Roll Along, which was a history of the automobile in the United States. They got groucho marks to host it, and in this show, groucho marks introduced Americans to
我们都听过的论点，那就是美国人对汽车有一种迷恋。我们欢快地唱着关于一起在汽车里度过一生，并与我们的新爱人开始了漫长的蜜月。如果他有什么缺点，那就是有点脾气暴躁。所以，这就是“迷恋论”，它的天才之处在于，通过说我们对汽车有迷恋，我们是在说我们的关系是不理性的，不受逻辑判断的约束。如果那不是婚姻，我不知道什么才是。我们一起经历了两次战争和一次大萧条。她载着我们穿过了航空时代，进入了原子时代。
the thesis we've all heard, which is that there's an American love affair with the automobile. We sang blively about automobubbling through life together together and started out on the long honeymoon with our new sweetheart If he had any fault, it was a slight crankiness So um that's the love affair thesis and the genius of it is that by saying we have a love affair with the car We are saying that our relationship is irrational and not subject to logical judgment that a relationship is irrational and not subject to logical judgment. If that isn't marriage, I don't know what is. We've been through two wars together in a depression. She's carried us through the air age and into the atomic age.
无论我们现在要去哪里，都会乘坐像这样的东西。它可能是核动力、雷达控制、陀螺仪稳定和维生素强化。但它后面会有车牌、前灯和喇叭，偶尔我们还得下车推它一把。所以，我们快乐地前行。甚至包括我在内的汽车批评者，我们也接受了这种美国人对汽车迷恋的观点。因为汽车的批评者会说，你知道，看，这种迷恋，这种
Wherever we're headed now, it'll be in something like this. It may be nuclear power, radar control, gyroro state and vitamin enriched. But it'll have license plates from the back, headlights and a horn, and once in a while we'll still have to get out and give it a shove. So, merrily we roll along. And even critics of cars, including me, we've bought into this idea of an American love affair with the automobile. Because the critics of the automobile could say, you know, look, this love affair, this
我们对汽车的文化依恋，才是问题所在，这完全分散了他们的注意力，使他们忽略了20世纪转型的真实故事要复杂得多，事实上涉及很多对汽车的仇恨。我的意思是，你在20年代看到了对汽车真正的妖魔化，这已经被完全遗忘了。没有人记得对汽车的纪念活动。没有人记得纪念碑，没有人记得撒旦驾驶T型车的游行，没有人记得漫画，那些经常把汽车比作死神、摩洛克和主宰等的社论漫画。诚然，美国人喜欢汽车。但我们如此热爱汽车的部分原因是我们的城市是按照汽车的理念重建的。
cultural attachment we have to the automobiles, the problem, which completely distracted them from the fact that the actual story of the transformation of the 1920s was a lot more complicated, and in fact involved a lot of hate of the car. I mean, you see real demonization of the car in the 20s that's been totally forgotten. Nobody remembers the memorials to the car. Nobody remembers the monuments, nobody remembers the parades with Satan driving a Model T, nobody remembers the cartoons, the editorial cartoons that routinely compared cars to the Grim Reaper and Milwaukee and Juggernaut and all that. And it's true that Americans love cars. But part of the reason we love cars so much is our cities have been rebuilt with cars in mind.
我们有停车场，我们有高速公路，我们没有很多行人挡路并减慢我们的速度，这可能正在改变，但目前，我们似乎仍然喜欢那样。[♪ 音乐] 《99% Invisible》本周由杰西·杜克斯、萨姆·格林斯潘和我罗曼·马尔斯制作。特别感谢“Snap Judgment”广播剧团的疯狂历史和非历史重演技巧，帕特·米西·德·米勒、尼克·范德库尔克、阿纳苏斯曼、斯蒂芬妮·福、朱莉娅·德威特和威尔·乌尔比纳。
We have parking, we have expressways, we don't have a lot of pedestrians getting in our way and slowing us down, and it may be changing, but for the moment, we still seem to like it that way. [♪ Music Invisible was produced this week by Jesse Duke's Sam Greenspan and me Roman Mars. Special thanks to the Snap Judgment radio players for their mad historical and not-so historical, re-enacting skills, Pat Misee de Miller, Nick Vanderkulk, Anasusman, Stephanie Foo, Julia DeWitt, and Will Urbina.
你们听这个的人，都听《Snap Judgment》，对吧？当然你们听。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到《99% Invisible》。我在Twitter上叫Roman Mars，但我们将会有《现代摩洛克》漫画、乱穿马路禁忌之前市场街的迷人影片，以及格劳乔为广播电台做广告的视频链接。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。
You guys listening to this all, listen to Snap Judgment, right? Of course you do. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco, and the American Institute of Architects in San Francisco. You can find 99% invisible on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars, but we'll have the modern malloc cartoon of fascinating film of Market Street before the J-walking taboo, and a link to the video of Groucho Shilling Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你们听这个节目的都在听Snap Judgment，对吧？当然是这样。我们是旧金山91.7本地公共广播电台KALW和旧金山美国建筑师协会的一个项目。你可以在Facebook上找到99% Invisible。我在推特上关注Roman Mars，但我们会提供关于市场街在行人违规过马路禁令实施前的迷人影片的现代malloc卡通，以及Groucho Shilling Radio tapio视频的链接。来自PRX。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。